مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره ومعي انا عبيده
[موسيقى]
انتقال نيمار الى الهلال شوف نيمار في
حواليه وجهتين نظر في وجهه نظر انه هو
بيليه جديد هذا كان لقبه اول ما بلش مع
سانتوس والناس كلها كانت شبهه وفي لقب
اطلع عليه مؤخرا او وجهه نظر بحقه مؤخرا
كانت انه هو اسوا صفقه بتاريخ كره القدم
ليش شافوا بعض المحللين والاعلاميين انه
نيمار هو بلال جديد وليش شافوا اخرين هو
اسوا صفقه بتاريخ كره القدم وليش في ناس
متفقه مع واجهتين النظر سوا ولما بنحكي عن
اسوا صفقه نحن مش عم نحكي عن صفقه انتقال
للهلال للتوضيح عم نحكي عن صفقه انتقاله
لباريس سان جيرمان من برشلونه الناس اللي
شايفه انه هو بيليه جديد كانت شايفه هيك
لانه نيمار عنده موهبه كبيره جدا عنده
قدرات هائله مقارنه باللاعبين من نفس جيلو
او حتى الاقدم منه وبالتالي كانوا شايفين
انه الموهبه اللي عنده نادره جدا وما اجت
من وقت وكانوا مراهنين عليه انه هو يكون
واحد من اهم اللاعبين اللي راح يقود
البرازيل المجد واعتقد انه جزء من نهايه
التسميه كان لاسباب تسويقيه مشان يبيعوه
باكبر سعر ممكن لبرشلونه او لريال مدريد
اللي كان الاثنين عم يتنافسوا عليه اما
ليش هو اسوا صفقه بتاريخ كره القدم حسب ما
سموه البعض نيمار انتقل من برشلونه على
باريس سان جيرمان مقابل اكثر من 240 مليون
دولار عام 2017 وهذا الانتقال كان عليه
يعني علامات استفهام كبيره والناس صارت
تتهم نيمار انه هو رايح على باريس سان
جيرمان من اجل المال فقط انه هو ضحى
بمستقبل الكروي وامكانيه المنافسه الكره
الذهبيه من شان يروح ياخذ الاموال وهي
وجهه نظر ولكن في وجهه نظر اخرى بتقول انه
هو كان مامن بمشروع باريس سان جيرمان انه
ممكن يحقق لقب دوري الابطال مع باريس
ويكون نجم الفريق الاوحد ويطلع من ضل ميسي
في برشلونه
فترته مع باريس سان جيرمان من 2017 الى
2023 كانت فتره ما فيها انجازات كبيره
اكبر انجاز اوروبي حققوا نيمار كانوا وصل
لنهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا 2020 مع البي اس
جي ما عدا ذلك اللي هو القاب دوري طبيعيه
جدا بجيبها باريس سان جيرمان بشكل اعتيادي
وطبيعي جدا وما نافس ولا مره على الكره
الذهبيه وما كان له اي تاثير او وجود على
الساحه بما يخص الكره الذهبيه او الجوائز
الفرديه على مستوى اوروبا والعالم لذلك
شاف البعض انه نيمار الامان اللي كانت
معلقه عليه والمبلغ اللي انتقل فيه اللي
هو اكبر مبلغ بتاريخ كره القدم لانتقال
لاعب من نادي الى نادي يعني كان كثير كبير
صراحه على اللي قدموا مع باريس سان جيرمان
وشافوا انه الصفقه كان صفقه سيئه جدا
وخصوصا انه اللاعب بست مواسم او بست سنوات
مع الفريق الباريسي ما لعب اكثر من 22
مباراه بالدوري في موسم واحد هذا بيدل عنه
كان يتعرض لكثير اصابات بدل على انه ما
كان جاهز مدنيا لانه يكون مفيد لباريس سان
جيرمان
طب هذا الكلام لوين بودينا وشو دخله بصفقه
او انتقال نيمار على الهلال نيمار
بانتقاله الى الهلال قرر انه ينهي مسيرته
بشكل تام باوروبا هلا قال هو بيعود بيرجع
لاحقا الى اوروبا بنافس مره اخرى باحد
الانديه هاي فرضيه وامكانيه ممكنه ولكن
لحد الان او على المدى المنظور شايفين انه
نيمار لمده موسمين موجود مع الهلال
السعودي والهلال بالتاكيد هو فريق كبير
ولكن اهدافه من التعاقد مع نيمار اكيد مش
اهداف رياضيه بحته لانه هو بيعرف كثير
منيح انه نيمار نعم قادر يضيف للفريق ولكن
بنفس الوقت اصاباته كثيره مشاكله كثيره
حتى داخل الملعب ايام ما كان باسبانيا
اعتقد بتتذكروا كيف كان يعمل مشاكل مع
لاعبين اتلتيكو مدريد بسبب استفزاز الخصوم
وتشافي كان دائما على مشاكل وخلافات معه
بسبب هذا الموضوع وبالمناسبه يمكن هاي
النقطه كانت واحده من نقاط الاساسيه اللي
ما خلت تتشافي يتشجع انه يتعاقد معه
ويجيبوا على برشلونه الى جانب العوائق
الماديه اللي كانت موجوده بهذه الصفقه
فالهدف من جلب نيمار هو هدف تسويقي بلا شك
بالنسبه للهلال وتسويقيا صفقه نيمار صفقه
ناجحه 100% لاي فريق ان كان باريس سان
جيرمان ولا ان كان الهلال ولا كان اي فريق
اخر انك تجيب نيمار لعندك فنمار هو قيمه
تسويقيه ثابته اول شيء عنده طبعا عدد
متابعين كبير على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
في ناس بتحبه بتعشقه وبتعتبره الافضل
بالعالم وبالتاريخ يمكن وفي ناس اكيد راح
تتابع الهلال بشكل كثير كبير بسبب وجود
نيمار ان كانوا عاشقين لنيمار ولا ان
كانوا حتى معجبين بطريقه لعبه او باسلوب
لعبه بقادرينه على انه لاعب كبير وبالتالي
تسويقيا صفقه نيمار صفقه رائعه ولا يشق
لها غبار بالدوري السعودي ويمكن حتى افضل
من صفقه كريم بنزيما على اتحاد جده لانه
نيمار هو نجم شباك كما يقال وبيهتم كثير
بالشوق اما على الصعيد الرياضي فمثل ما
حكينا اللاعب سواته كثيره لاعب جوا الملعب
مشاكله كبيره وبالتالي لا اعتقد انه
هي صفقه ممتازه بالنسبه للهلال اكيد نيمار
موهبه عظيمه جدا ولكن سؤال لجمهور الهلالي
وسؤال للجميع او المهتمين بشان الكره
والسعودي مع وجود سالم الدوسري على الجناح
الايسر بالنسبه للهلال هل كان الهلال
بحاجه نيمار في هذا المركز ولا انه سالم
الدوسري كان مكفي وموفي ممكن الان نيمار
يستغل كلاعب صانع لعب احتمال ممكن يلعب
كمهاجم وهمي كمان احتمال ولكن هو مركز
الاساسي انه يلعب جناح يمين او يسار هاي
امور رح تختلف ولكن اعتقد بوجود سالم
الدوسري وحتى ميشيل مع الهلال الهلال كان
قادر يحقق لقب دوري ابطال اسيا كان قادر
ينافس دائما ويسيطر على الكره الاسيويه لا
بل انه ذهب الى العالميه ووصل لنهائي كاس
العالم للانديه وخسر امام ريال مدريد لذلك
صفقه نيمار راح يكون لها تاثير كبير
بالتاكيد على الدوري السعودي تاثير كبير
على نادي الهلال ولكن لحد الان عندي
علامات استفهام كبيره جدا على تاثيره
الرياض هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض
الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل